so my name is Alexy and today I'm going
to talk about vandalism detection in
knowledge base so first keywords about
me so my background is databases so I
did my bachelor in information systems
and then I worked the Java developer for
a few years and then I decided to go
into data analytics I did the Masters in
bi and then after that I started working
as a data scientist in my free time I
participate in data science competitions
and today my dog will be about one of
those competitions which is about
predicting vandalism in knowledge bases
I'm also broad no member of open data
science this is a community of Russians
begin data scientists so if you speak
Russian and not there yet please go
there in join so this is the place where
I actually learned about this
competition and yes like the platform is
not very famous so so let's start so
what is the knowledge base a knowledge
base is a machine-readable
database like machine readable way of
representing knowledge and typically
like today like most widespread way of
represented knowledge is a inform Rd
inform RDF triples which is subject
predicate object and then subject and
object are some entities or concepts and
then ready gave describes the relation
between two entities so for instance
when I studied at tu Berlin my professor
who was teaching machine learning was a
cloud server browser and we can
represent this knowledge in this graph
so Klaus Robert Miller works at T Berlin
and he teaches machine learning and with
that approach with such graphs we can
represent basically anything we want and
so constants machine learning is also
part of computer science so this way we
have a linked graph of things and we can
use that for many things for instance
it's very useful for enhancing user
experience or in some way when you go to
Google and when you want to search for
something for instance for some movie
and you look for Titanic and Google
recognizes that any case a movie and it
shows you some additional information
like the cost of Titanic when it was
filmed and so on this is done all thanks
to knowledgebase
so of course you see that videos very
useful and it's very expensive to obtain
such database because a good quality
knowledge basis should be created by
hand like there are automatic ways but
they usually have not as good quality as
good knowledge bases and one or such
knowledge base is wiki data so the key
data is a project by like at 4 cm IDs
Wiki Wikipedia so Wikipedia is a free
encyclopedia and wiki data is a free
knowledge base everybody can go to the
wiki data and enter whatever information
they want so this is very useful but
unfortunately some people abuse the
system and put incorrect information
offensive information they can put the
effort they can put something that is
not true for instance here we see that
machine learning page from Viki data so
this is a page about machine learning
and you can go there and put some useful
facts about machine learning for
instance I go there and I don't like
ocean learning and I go there and say ok
machine learning is pseudoscience for 3d
Sciences and I can save it and then all
the systems that use this data will
think that machine learning is not
really I think yeah so to fight that
wiki data employs moderators who go
through all suggested edits
also there's two divisions and they
mainly say ok this is this revision is
good we approve it or no this revision
is not good we roll it back and
of course we can help moderators and use
machine learning for that to like
because they may need it have to go
through many many many revisions it's
quite popular nowadays and yeah what we
can do is we can use machine learning to
help them to have a short the shortlist
of candidates candidate revisions that
they should go through and manually from
decide if it means Rebecca not so that
means the organizers of wisdom cup they
collected the data of wiki data
revisions and they challenge the data
science community to build such a model
to self moderators so the goal of this
competition was given a revision the
model should predict if this revision
should be product or not because anybody
participated in tackle competitions okay
so you know like in cargo you really
like the organizers we provide train
dataset they provide us data set and
they provide labels for chain dataset
participants download all the data sets
they train model on train data they
apply to test data and they upload
predictions this is how it's done on
goggle and then you immediately see
results on the leaderboard it's not like
that
it's very different so here instead of
the billion predictions participants
submitted code and this code was in a
virtual machine so and participants
never saw actually test data all they
did was submitting the code then Quadron
so it listen to some circuit where it
reads data from then model was applied
and send back the predictions and this
virtual machines had some hardware
limitations so there was only one core
one CPU and four gigs from and this is
how it look like so like there we just
needed to provide some comment which
needed to be executed and hit RAM at the
end and like Kargil Greece nothing it
just says okay the run was successful or
not
on cargo you usually see some scores and
here is messy
it's okay the problem the days left
dataset so the data set was provided in
row dump the dump from Wikipedia from
the end of from the beginning of times
till 2016 it was 72 million revisions
quite a large dataset and when
uncompressed it was almost half a
terabyte of data pretty large and it was
also very skewed because most of the
revisions they are good and only a
quarter of percent either roll back so
it's very skewed and most of the
examples their negatives
their negatives they are good they don't
put the V roll back
so before approaching before starting
training model like everybody should
think ok how we are going to validate
this model organizers actually sort of
that and they provided a split of data
into three parts train validation and
test but the third test was never
released so it it was only accessible
through the virtual machine so what
participants had was training data and
validation data and from that I took
this data and did speed myself so I took
validation data as test and then the
beginning of 2016
I used the validation data and I took
only the data for 2015's test so I took
only a small part of revisions because I
thought the way one dog behaves now it's
probably different from the way one dogs
behave in 2012 so probably should
concentrate only on the most recent data
and not only that also like the data set
was quite large and somehow I needed to
process it so I had only 32 gigs of RAM
on my machine so like looking only at
one year of data was enough to actually
fit this data send it around
taking more round bottom graph so this
is how the data looks like so this is
one of the pages from the dump so here
we have title of the page
we have some information about division
who was the users user who suggests the
television username if the username is
not not locked into wiki data then we
have the IP address of that user we have
some comments there and then we have the
actual content of the entire page in
form like in JSON format so what we can
use for machine learning here for our
model apparently we can take title there
because some of the pages there are
maybe more controversial than others and
they are targeted more often by bundles
than others so for instance the page
about the term probably it is more often
than a page about snails and yeah so it
totally makes sense to include title
there then of course it could also use
user because some users maybe they tend
to be more on dialect and others and
it's not only user it's also the IP of
the user when it the user is not logged
in then for the revisions we also have
comments and we have the JSON format so
I didn't use JSON content because it was
too big and it wasn't really possible to
to see eight to two revisions and see
what changed between those two revisions
so it was too too cumbersome so I
decided not to use the content and used
on the title username and comment so for
titled simple I just take the title and
use it as a teacher user it's a bit more
complex because like we not only have
user name by type II so if user is not
locked in then we say okay user is
anonymous and then we look at their be
and try to extract some useful features
from the ID so of course the most
straightforward think we can do with
type II is just take I P itself and use
it as a feature but sometimes some
people they probably maybe they have
dynamic IP
every time they go to Internet baby
changes so it also makes sense to look
at the subnet so maybe the last digit
changes but the three things before they
stay the same so the next time user goes
in to Internet and tries to make
offensive offensive edits to wiki data
then yeah we should get this user and
then also from IP we can get information
about geography of that user like
country like this particular user was
from the UK which is in Great Britain
which is in European Union so we can use
that and the way we use it is one
protein-coding so what one what encoding
is is basically we take like every
possible feature we have a very large
Mattox and then for each feature we put
one there if we see this each other so
for instance if we see that this user is
from Great Britain then we put one
against Great Britain the way I did this
was I usually work with text so I just
put all these features together in one
string I'd recognize it from space and
then I use County Treasurer from
scikit-learn to actually build that
Mattox so what it does contractor is an
inside it looks at each token and then
it is okay this token goes to column
number 100 and then it is one there and
then the systematics that we can work
with and use machine learning for that
so that is for user so if user is logged
in then we also have all we know what
the user is just easily then we have
comments feature common features it's a
bit more structured so here are four
examples of comments so apparently this
is machine generated and we can see that
there are multiple parts the part the
structures part inside the comment
things so we can take it and again
decompose it into tokens and then use
that as our one hot encoding Mattox and
then the second comment is interesting
because we see that there is inter vicky
links saying this double square brackets
so when we want to add a fact about a
certain entity then the model the system
generates comments that looks like that
and so when I say that
machine learning is pseudoscience then
is a property which gets some name and
pseudoscience is also a concept in wiki
data which also have some code name and
for instance in Vicky's in Vicky's data
they have a special page for crap and if
somebody says a game machine learning is
crap then we can use that to actually
see that this is probably one Dalek and
yeah so the model should figure that out
and also there is some free text outside
of the comments like courage in the
browser we can just take it and use as
usual new real text and we can put this
in this one certain column attics and
yeah train machine learning model so
here we have very large modulus is where
it's parsed very high dimensionality
what we should do with this one this is
what kind of model we should use so when
I have a problem like that the first
thing I do is a train an SVM linear SVM
with l1 penalty which produces sparse
solutions and this is usually the model
that I use as a baseline and more often
than not this is the model I end up
using at the end after trying multiple
other things so what I did here was I
took each feature like title feature
user feature like all other features
from comments alone and then I tried to
build as a model on them and so what is
the what is the performance of this
feature with SEM so you see that ok so
it takes a while because like linear AC
from scikit-learn it uses zlib linear
insight which is a parallel transponder
on one core but still like half an hour
for like a lot of data is additional
performance yeah so they see that like
just using user features we can already
get 92 percent of easy so this is pretty
decent so can we do better on cargo like
people who ever participated MOOC ago
know that usually the way to achieve
good performance
is combined models is take several
models and assemble them so I thought
okay I should do the same and just take
the output of these models put them
together so what we do is we train each
model separately then we take output of
this model put them together and train
another model on top of that and this is
called stacking and this I do that here
in hope that it will be very good and
indeed on like the numbers that I got on
validation books promising like it was
one percent better than previously but
then I checked this against my test
dataset and it turned out that it wasn't
really that good it was as good as a
user feature as user at the end that I
had
so apparently because of these high
skewness of the data this example picked
up some noise and then they all fit so
okay I thought the data is cute what we
can do that when the data is cute then
there is a class imbalance would like
there are multiple ways to fight this
imbalance is there the model and most
popular ways is over sample the majority
class or in the sample the majority
class so we take one class and then with
sample with replacement from tenth class
and you reach a certain proportion that
we want so 50 50 or 70 200 70/30 yeah
and I tried that I was I spent quite a
lot of time trying to find the right
proportion and see if it helps and then
it was all not helpful
so the reason I for that I think is when
we train the model on the entire data it
rather learns the negative examples so
it is what revisions are good and tear
quite diverse and then we remove this
information when we understand pull the
majority class we lose this information
about good revisions and yeah when we
apply this to unseen data it it becomes
worse
and the same with us over something
because I think like there are so few
but revisions that when we over sample
the model gets like it over fits
basically yes so at the end I just took
all these features all this parse
mattresses put them together and turn a
single experiment on that but there was
a problem so remember at the beginning I
said that the code should be run in
within a virtual machine and these
fictional machines had hardware
limitations so there was only four
gigabytes of RAM but when I did that the
dictionary was too large so what I mean
the dictionary is when we try to build
this large one cotton cotton Mattox we
need to figure out where each talking in
this Mattox goes so we know that if user
if if user has username username then we
put one into call number zero then if
this user is anonymous and it's from
Great Britain then we could put seven
into put one into number into call
number seven and so on we need to keep
track of these tokens and they're where
they go and it results in a very large
huge dictionary and this is a problem
because at the end it occupied like two
gigabytes of RAM and the way I needed to
do this is I trained this vectorizer
a save it put it into virtual machine
and then in virtual machine when I keep
this against test data this needs to be
loaded into memory and then there is not
enough RAM for other things so there is
other way of doing this one hood
encoding and this is called hashing
click and it's implemented in
scikit-learn
in session vectorizer so instead of
keeping this dictionary of this mapping
from talking to column number what we
can do is just take tag talking then
compute the hash of this token modulo
some big number and that would be the
index of the column where we put 1 so
clearly we don't need a dictionary now
so it's it's actually quite small
memory because all we need is take cash
and decide where it goes but again there
could be some collisions because the
same tokens could map into one bucket so
there is a trade-off and the the feature
space like the dimensionality of this
one Hotel automatics will be quite large
too to make sure that we have a few
collusion collisions as possible
this was my final model so I used one
hot encoding with this session
vectorizer quest no memory but on the
other side
inside the wait for the model were quite
larger so because the dimensionality of
this one code encoding is quite large
then we have more parameters and then
they took take more spice but it's 300
megabytes is both less than 2 gigs yeah
and with that model I was able to
achieve 96% of a she and I used that I
decided to use it that was my final rose
and that's the final result so like
during the competition I never knew how
well I perform against other teams and
then finally they released the final
standings and I turned out to be 2nd
Smither yeah and if you see here no can
you see the cursor the run time is
because I wanted to use a very simple
model and I used this session 3 contest
be am with a linear model which is very
good it resulted in very good run time
so it was a few million applications so
I needed to rhythms from circuit and
read back so it likely some overhead but
again the other guys it probably use
some dip nuts I don't know yeah so it
was a lot faster than anything else and
not as but of course like it still 1
percent worse than the first place yeah
I still don't know what they used
because yeah so I'll probably know that
at some point so conclusions from that
so here unlike in Google I cannot check
my
against the leader work so I have to
really trust my cross validation so the
validation scheme that I built I have to
really make certain that it's good and
then yeah and use that and clearly
trusted again it was one of these
unusual cases wherein something didn't
work so sometimes it can happen and
again if you have proper cross
validation scheme then it should be
possible to to catch that like that
insulin doesn't work that it were of it
and yet the nth I preferred simple
models to more complex ones and that
resulted in good run time and yeah I was
able to award weight over fitting one of
the tools I use here was whether anybody
heard of this either so it's a special
tool for which stores data frames bundle
data frames into a columnar binary
format it works really fast so compared
to like you can of course take data
frame save it to CSV or you can take
that of raiment save it typical or you
can use fever which would be ten times
faster and on such data sets like this
it was really helpful
I could experiment because the data set
was so large so and it was it was able
to read these data frames very quick so
I totally recommend this library and it
also works in Python and are so you can
do something Python and then read it
from our end the other way around
and then since it was a conference
competition it was also possible to
submit a paper with the approach to the
workshop at the conference which is what
I did and it got accepted it's not
published yet and other other teams I
hope to do the same and when it's
published I hope I should be able to
beat the approaches about the approaches
that taste but it's probably something
more complex than anything so all the
code is of course open source you can go
check it have
and you can read more about composition
itself and the platform with this
virtual machine that they used so I
actually I presented this like I gave
this presentation already to TV media
they likely have an office here in
Berlin and they what they do is they
work with big data so there are actually
people sitting here in Berlin who who
need that and I presented my approach
there and they say that my approach is
the easiest to integrate because like
it's feasible to actually uses and that
in production because it's fast they can
take it as is because the data is
running on HP so they need to modify it
but since it uses this hashing tick all
they need to do is take some token hash
it and then take the waste so they are
definitely going to integrate this at
some point yeah so the talk is almost
over but yeah I wrote a book about Java
for data science I know that it's a
weird place to promote the Java book in
the Python conference I know yeah but if
anybody is interested I have a free copy
here so come to me and talk
[Applause]
so thank you thank you for the talk it's
really amazing to see like someone
actually doing like a project and
getting a team to like use and all of
that like former competition I have many
many questions especially about Java for
data Sciences it sounds like an oxymoron
they'll ask you later in private what I
really am wondering about is what you
learn about distinguishing or not
co-option how do you call it
vandalism what you learned like from the
model about distinguishing vandalism
because then like it's a sort of black
box so you can see and so can understand
the features we can insert the
coefficients what do you learn about the
detecting vandalism and input and in
general what did you learn about doing
this kind of project what's like a
take-home message about the model itself
so take-home was already I mentioned
that like trusting your validation
scheme and yeah that was the most
important thing content sometimes in
samples don't work
of course like SEM is a linear model and
I can look at coefficients and see what
is the most like a stronger signal that
a revision is on daleks I did that and
it turned out that many bundles are from
Spain I don't know yeah so I looked at
like top 10 features by like the weight
of confusion Cynthia Spain was there and
there was a my piece like IB sub-ranges
like I have no idea I just thought okay
ideas vary so the user features table
almost like most useful in that so its
user who helps like accept some group of
people who usually make these Wonderlic
changes
like it was shown maybe I left fun in
the end if we have time question thanks
to the talk so you said first of all
there was a 400 gig data set so I if I
understand correctly you process that
into a sparse matrix is like getting the
features so the first question is how
much how many rows were there once even
after process and second is just roughly
how much how much ram would have got
taken so yeah I have answer here so when
I split here so the training was almost
30 millions of revisions so this was the
number of rows in the sparse Mattox and
on Navajo of course before creating the
final model like tube train validation
into one magics like together and train
to the final model there so and then it
was like 35 millions of training
examples and it was able to fit into 32
gigs of ram so because i didn't use this
the content of each revision which was
the raw JSON file which i think took
most of the space yeah
and of course if i wanted to include
more data for instance for year 2014
then it wouldn't be like my computer
wouldn't be enough so i actually try to
using some online methods like the
classic gradient descent classifier from
second learn it was worse than just
taking this year 2015
thank you for the talk at the end you
mentioned that you use feather
have you tried hdf5 yes it's a bit too
bit it takes more time yes okay okay so
maybe let me ask one more question so so
you mentioned that a lot of vendor lists
are from Spain and now I want to learn
something from from this you know I want
to learn something from the project
suppose I kidded about my how to solve
my problems and I kind of want a way to
so I'm going to train a model in two and
two and to test it but I don't think it
will work as well so I'm kind of trying
to learn how you expected like it's
vandalism really a country dependent or
is it just due to us
okay so they all say is 0.96 is this is
like a real result well there you taught
a classifier to understand vandalism or
is it like you kind of studied how
vandalism looks in particular months or
years and then it will change all the
time and we have to retrain it is there
any kind of deep insight to learn about
how to work with big couple of texts
about detecting vandalism or something
else for them so it's a few questions so
so the first was like the first thing is
actually it's not about detecting
vandalism it's about detecting if this
revision should be rolled back not and
we assume that a cave revision is
rollback is because of undal ism so we
just make this assumption and I think
it's pretty a good assumption because
usually that the reason why revisions
are all back but because there's so many
like because of the skew in the data if
you like possible to overwhelm the
moderators with shortlist and now it
should be easier of course
so it should be useful in theory but for
VK media like they still have to to put
this and see if it's really helpful
because like from my point of view like
90 percent of a he is quite good usually
but when there is such strong skew it's
hard to say yeah so I hope it's useful
for them last question okay so let's go
[Applause]